une première en ile-de-france se vendit
20 avril une cérémonie a été organisée
sur le camp de ben pour récompenser la
fin de stage de la première promotion
des cadets de la gendarmerie de la
région parisienne
c'est un symbole les cérémonies
militaires sont en tout ont une portée
symbolique pour marquer leur intégration
et leur appartenance à la grande famille
à la grande communauté gendarmerie
cette année quinze lycéens âgés de 17 à
21 ans ont intégré cette filière
d'excellence
ils ont reçu leur diplôme devant leurs
proches ça fait plaisir de rendre fiers
nous nos aînés nos parents nous notre
famille nos cadres sata tenir les
futures générations à s'y engager aussi
ce serait un très bon entraîneur pour
les soutenir l'ex boxeur jean marc
mormeck actuellement délégué
interministériel à l'égalité des chances
des français d'outre-mer s'est rendu sur
place en tant que parrain de la
promotion
moi je suis très content de voir cette
jeunesse ou que l'on parle positivement
aujourd'hui qui font des choses et on
parle beaucoup de jeunes qui font des
choses négatives mais aussi vous parler
des jeunes qui s'investissent et qui
veulent faire les choses prochaine étape
pour les lycéens de la promotion le
baccalauréat dans quelques semaines une
fois leur diplôme obtenu les intégrerons
pour la plupart la gendarmerie